[Music]
hello and welcome to this video this is
the video on the chapter on the reversed
Grunfeld yeah we have a reversed
Greenfeld chapter because if you think
about this a little bit what we are
doing our opening approach with
combining d4 Knight f3 and g3 is quite
similar to what happens in the green
felt when black plays this opening like
look at this leg is essentially
combining the King selfie and Cairo with
the D pawn push and we are doing the
same with white which means that there
can be something that you can call the
reverse guna and this is the following
line d 4 D 5 a day 3 9 f 6 g 3 and now
black playing c5
like is attacking our Center and maybe
we'll actually take their which would
really lead to something that can be
clearly classified as a reverse
Greenford SC porn has trailed Ford upon
our night comes to deform and so on um
before we and I could look into this a
little bit more I wanted to briefly
mention that this set up with c5 and d5
can also be prepared with a six so black
could also play it's a six year we
played g3 they play c5 if we play Bishop
g2 and black takes and so on this is
possible but it doesn't really have any
independent value as blackboard play
Knight f6 very soon anyway for example
here after the capture Knight takes
Knight f6 is clearly a move on in fact
we can also pass on your first witch
after Knight f6 94 would also be
transposing so we basically have no
independent value in early success and
we should focus on the usual move order
of Knight f6 g3 c5 and here we play
Bishop g2 of course now um the main
continuation here is oblique to take on
deform at some point you can do that
here or you can do that in some move
some moves later for example um 96
castles eggs would be a way to do that
on right away which is a difference and
the difference is that if we capture on
d4 now we've only first were Castle but
here that can be the difference that
there is no knight on c6 that we can
take we'll discuss that in a moment the
other approach that Black has is
something like knight c6 we Castle black
play c6 we play c4 and we have basically
now completed our standard set of moves
as we do quite often in many lines like
the Catalan or
um summary aerolites queen's indian for
example this is a very standard setup we
have played d4 c4 and fianchettoed yep
it's important to see if they now take
on d4 we have this scenario that we've
discussed before black takes their leg
may also take here which is the final
art of this chapter one you can play
Bishop e7 after which all of a sudden we
can transpose into a tirage so basically
if black keeps the tension with c5 and
d5 we will often end up in a taraji
defense that is covered in chapter 2 on
the rear a d4 d5 lines the most
important party of this chapter will be
featuring black taking on d4 and we put
yeah we look at this shortly a smallish
independent option here would be for
black to play six and after Castle is
something like Bishop to e7 this is a
bit rare but it sometimes happens we
still play c4 and now again like the
very often transpose somewhere else for
example castling would be a tirage or
they can take on default after 94 we
look at a position that we will examine
shortly in the in the main repertoire
when black takes on d4 a smallish
independent option would be for black to
take on c4 here which we can answer in
more than one good way D takes e5 is a
good move but I recommend Queen a4 where
you get the pawn back easily
yeah should be seven queen takes now
black can also play 97 this is quite
funny Liam a position that we have
looked at or that we examine in the
Catalan chapter yeah they can go a six
and we go Quincey to for a nice
advantage this is checked in the in the
Catalan chapter but all those moves are
very natural anyway
we take on c4 after Bishop d7 and after
Bishop to c6
it's an idea for black for short you
trying to neutralize the bishop we can
simply take the pawn
like it's not really in a good position
here get it back he will get it back but
under terms that are not very favorable
yeah we will keep it covered before ice
not so good you to a5 but we can cover
it with the bishop move and here like
we'll finally play b6 to make sure that
he gets it back now you know of course
cannot take you to the discovery after
rook to e1 or ever castles and rooks e1
we get to a point where black cannot
really avoid B takes e5 anymore and then
we will have really the better corn
structure with the C pawn being weak and
this line is rather rare as mentioned
but it is one of the few independent
possibilities with an early been early
is six IAM again most of the time they
will take or play Knight to c6 after the
capture it is really important now
remember that you should not take on
deform the reason behind this is not
something like 96 that is a line that we
would be happy to play but the problem
is Knight is 'if I've I'm sorry
when our Knight has no good option we
will probably have to go to b3 which is
rather unfavorable sorry rather
unfavorable square the knight is passive
and we can also easily attack the center
with c4
this is something that we have in our
repertoire in a quite similar way with
white if you look at the chapter on the
goon field where we take the white side
against the green side setup we will
examine this variation where the same
thing happens here to the black side
they don't have anything to capture have
to go into a passive Square your white
is quite substantially better and this
is why I'm in this situation after the
capture we shouldn't take but we should
Castle this is a lot better we're just
waiting one move and ask black about a
decision and in fact
quite often black will play 96 and
simply yeah go into something that we
really don't mind playing the reversed
room filled with the capture on the 401
c6 is I think quite good for white and
something that I will present to you and
some some sometime later in this video
it will be a long one
anyway much ground to cover um now what
other option does black have the main
theoretical argument against White's
overall strategy is to delay the move
knight c6 and somehow ask wide okay what
are you doing do do you want to take on
d4 maybe later and still allow e5 um the
most sophisticated tries to do that are
aged six and Bishop to d7 err they they
look not very natural to me and I think
it's very unlikely that you will meet
them in an irregular let's say a club
championship game or in a league game
when you play a non non professional but
they definitely have to be checked more
natural options here are a six and g6 um
I think I'm going to start him with
maybe the movie six yeah let's start
with this one after six we are running
out of useful waiting moves in a way and
now we should probably take and simply
say okay okay yeah it might be that you
can kick us with e5 but it takes two
moves is 65 so prepare to Greenfeld
situations when it's a proper room
filled with black hair playing the setup
we would even be like to tamp er yeah we
have white and we have e65 played in to
move so normally now black plays 625
which does not mean that that happens
all of the time we also have to check
Bishop e7 and Knight to c6
we have to keep in mind these positions
can easily easily arise from different
move orders yeah for example black would
have started with a 65 on the very first
moves taken on default only later 95
that is a quite regular occurrence and
very nice for white now
[Music]
you